Eagles Titans Eckhart scored the
game-winning touchdown in Super Bowl 50
- you saw it I know it came with just
over two minutes left in the game
finishing a 75 yard drive to put the
Eagles in front for good Zach Ertz joins
us from Bloomington Minnesota I'll bet
you haven't been to sleep tonight good
morning to you and congratulations
accurate sweer so glad you're here hey
thank you guys thanks for having me now
listen you guys were the underdogs but
somebody forgot to tell your team you
weren't supposed to win last night yeah
I mean the whole the whole playoff run
it's kind of been like this starting
against the Falcons we were the first
number one seed to be the underdogs at
home and then even I think was two weeks
ago against the Vikings we were
underdogs again and in this game we were
underdogs again and I think it was kind
of a rallying thing for our team for the
city I mean the city of Philadelphia is
all about the underdog listen it looked
fun to watch you guys but I'm wondering
what you were thinking just watching
while the rest were reviewing that call
what were you thinking because they
seemed to take a very long time yeah
seemed like an eternity
honestly I don't I didn't really know
what they were looking at at the time to
me it seemed pretty obvious but when
they were reviewing it for that long I
mean that's when doubt seeps in just a
little bit Zach on a plate like that and
you also had a crucial fourth down play
are you just reacting and then it goes
by in a blur or what were you thinking
in that moment when you caught the ball
and you saw the end zone right in front
of you yeah I mean that's just kind of
all the reaction all the preparation
that's gone into this year it started in
April last year and it's just been a
continuation of things we we practiced
so far at each and every day as a team I
think we practiced harder than probably
any NFL team it's pretty remarkable what
we do on the practice field each and
every week and at that point it's all
reaction you know Tom Brady is the king
of comebacks what was going through your
mind as the Patriots took the lead for
the first time with nine minutes to go I
mean anytime you're getting a shootout
with that guy
that's definitely not the ideal
situation that guy is the greatest
quarterback to ever walk there he
probably will be for a long long time so
I mean when they scored and we're down
one with I think nine minutes to go in
the game we had all the comments in the
world though we have to talk about wife
Julie because she's a champion - I love
the video of her crying when she found
out that you guys made it to the Super
Bowl please and yet one point you said
she's the best athlete in the family I'm
dying to know what you guys did last
night she was so happy for you
yeah she was so happy she was it would
be here out in Minnesota for this game
obviously two weeks ago her not being
there was extremely tough and then
watching her show how happy she was for
me it was emotional for me as well but
she was out here we were able to
celebrate together well that's great
well I know that I know your team
partied last night did you have some
dilly dilly oh yeah we got some Philly
Philly for sure I know Lane Johnson is
kind of in charge of that call so we
decided to get back to Philly and kind
of enjoy it with all of our fans
I know enjoy enjoy enjoy a lot of people
very happy for you this morning and I
can't imagine what they're doing in
Philly today Zach Ertz thank you very
much thanks guys thank you forever he's
a great guy you know a great guy about
him
yeah and his wife too you know a player
I'm just reading because Brady threw Tom
Brady he's human he said we know which
radio to think it was Brady Washington
or the Brady Bunch
here's a story but what did Tom Brady do
he threw for over five hundred yards but
both teams it was such an offensive
firework the both teams threw for over
1,100 yards that is the most yards in
any NFL game including the regular
season and playoffs so they both played
spectacularly really people who said I
don't know about both teams but I want
an exciting game and that's what they
got they absolutely got it in spades